david ducourneau pdg d'une enseigne de
sport de glisse à bordeaux bonsoir david
ducourneau merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous sur rt france j'imagine que vous
avez lu vous aussi c'est un 10 par
rapport à déconfinement progressif qui
n'est pas véritablement un déconfinement
mais en tout cas les commerces dits non
essentiels devraient pouvoir ouvrir
autour du 1er décembre
est ce que vous vous êtes de ceux qui
demandaient aussi à ce que les commerces
rouvrent dès le week-end prochain
bonsoir oui tout à fait on a
effectivement cette volonté de pouvoir
initier une réouverture dès le week-end
prochain ce qui permettrait de lisser la
charge sur un week-end de plus que le
avant noël est donc de permettre d'avoir
moins de couilles sur les dernier
week-end avant avant les sexes oui ça
permettrait évidemment de ne pas faire
l'impasse sur un week-end est essentiel
avant les fêtes
un des week-ends essentiel et n'avait
d'autre avant effectivement mais on a
déjà raté beaucoup et donc effectivement
il serait un essentiel je pense pour
beaucoup d'entre nous de pouvoir nourrir
pour pouvoir recommencer à faire du
chiffre d'affaires et on va entrer dans
un cycle quasi normal on va dire avant
dans cette pub vous en tant que pdg
d'une enseigne de sport de glisse c'est
à cette période de l'année que vous
faites le plus gros de votre chiffre
d'affaires oui effectivement et c'est
décidé le week-end très très gros ça a
commencé ce week-end si celui ci combien
de deux passes et fermé donc nous on a
une double activité qui est en commerce
et en commerces physiques et donc on a
eu effectivement moins d'impact puisque
on a eu toujours une activité de
e-commerce qui était déjà est
initialisée cependant le décalage du
black friday et toutes les autres
activités font que les chiffres
d'affaires ne sont pas bons rails ce
sport de glisse vous vend des sports de
glisse pour le ski également pour pour
la mer tout à fait oui alors les deux
bien sûr mais avec une grosse spécialité
sur les sports de montagne et donc on
attend aussi à la casse
de savoir comment vont se passer les
confinements potentiel des stations de
ski voilà c'était ma question également
vous allez pouvoir vendre ouvertement en
présentiel en tout cas ces articles mais
il ya toujours cette interrogation sur
les stations de ski
on sait que le déconfinement sera
progressif en trois phases autour des
fêtes de noël ça veut dire peut-être pas
une saison complète
quel impact pour votre activité
aujourd'hui les grands de toute façon
puisque notre activité est une activité
de pleine et donc on l'a fait avant le
départ en vacances donc l'impact et et
grands voire très très grand on ne sera
pas l'estimé le chiffrer avant d'avoir
réalisé le lan va dire la période des
fêtes de fin d'année mais aujourd'hui
l'impact est très grand et je pense
qu'il est très très grand pour la fin je
suis même sûr qu'il soit très très grand
pour toute la lune hiver des sports
outdoor est donc tous mes confrères est
aussi fournisseur et est donc
aujourd'hui on a un impact qui est qui
est très fort sur l'univers et au
toujours une restriction également qu'il
ya un cas un impact sur ce que vous
vendez sceller les personnes qui ne
peuvent pas faire de sport en tout cas
plus de deux en extérieur à plus d'un
kilomètre du domicile est ce que ça
aussi c'est ça une conséquence sur votre
activité
oui oui bien sûr tout ce qui est
activités de marche
le running on sont plus restreintes on
va dire pendant ces périodes où les gens
ne peuvent se déplacer qu'à un kilomètre
de chez eux donc forcément il ya un
impact
je pense que de toute façon la morosité
ambiante et l'esprit n'est pas là pour
faire des emplettes
et donc voilà il faudrait réussir malgré
la situation sanitaire que l'on sait
très compliqué à pouvoir se redonner des
perspectives en fait je pense que c'est
très attendue par tout le monde
c'est au delà de tout c'est d'avoir des
perspectives très précises sur
sur l'organisation et la façon dont on
va s'organiser piloter nos stocks et
savoir comment on va pouvoir imaginer
notre atterrissage de fin d'année plus
de lisibilité c'est ce qu'a promis en
tout cas emmanuel macron caton des
rouleaux de son discours mardi
concrètement on espère clairement lors
je parle au monde de plusieurs
fédérations de commerçants de que je
fais le parti on espère réellement que
kobo sa veuve rapidement on avait
imaginé le 27
historiquement bon je pense que c'est un
peu ample raté donc espérons le 28 parce
qu'un samedi est un jour de colère très
très fort qui représente presque les
autres jours de la semaine donc il ya
forcément cet impact qui est très grand
donc oui on espère on espère cette cette
capacité à pouvoir recevoir nos clients
de manière sécurisée de manière des
protocoles qu'on a déjà mis en place nos
petits commerces ont des très très
pointilleux sur le nombre de clients sur
les protocoles sanitaires avec les
masques les gels et donc là dessus
imaginez avoir l'aktéon tel héros vers
d'autres métiers parce que on est encore
une fois depuis un mois privé sur notre
métier et c'est d'une complexité grande
aujourd'hui on a trente salariés en
train de salir élections chômage partiel
et qui attendent de pouvoir revenir au
travail et avec un protocole sanitaire
renforcée c'est ce qui devra sans doute
être respectée a annoncé mardi ce sera
suffisant pour vous adapter pour une
ouverture éventuelle samedi oui oui tout
à fait à la ronde et je pense tous prêts
alors on a déjà eu des échanges en fait
sur ce protocole et on a participé les
lois sont ces derniers l'idée c'est bien
entendu de sécuriser au maximum tout ce
qui est envisageable pour le public
je pense qu'on est tous prêts la
problématique la plus grande encore une
fois et je les ai évoqué c'est la notion
de stock et donc ça on a plus ou moins
selon les différents commerces
anticipées
réassort et où l'achalandage est donc ce
sera la plus grande problématique mais
sur la partie sanitaire
on est tous prêts dernière question sur
la cohérence en tout cas de ces mesures
de restriction à en croire les
scientifiques et les messins l'activité
en plein air est plutôt bénéfique et il
n'y a pas grand risque de contamination
il est toujours interdit d'aller sur les
plages et faire des sports de glisse par
exemple comment comment est ce que
quelqu'un qu'en pensez vous je j'ai fait
la capacité à juger très honnêtement je
pense qu'il est complexe de faire la
dichotomie très précises entre les
différents univers et les différentes
autorisations et interdictions dont je
pense qu'il a été fait des halles entre
q parce qu'on n'était pas réellement les
éléments et donc on est on est contraint
de s'adapter régulièrement soit la
gronde soit aussi aux réalités
sanitaires et donc voilà je suis
honnêtement je serai pas critique
personnellement là dessus parce que bien
entendu que ça ne me sert pas mais pour
autant je n'ai pas la maîtrise
scientifique pour pouvoir dire que c'est
une bonne chose ou pas merci beaucoup en
tout cas david ducourneau d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions sur arte
france